Eingelagert bei minus 196 grad celsius und statt blut frostschutzmittel in den arterien. Und irgendwann wenn die forschung
So weit ist lässt man sich auf 1000 wieder zum
Leben erwecken nein das ist kein science fiction sondern der plan vieler menschen
Ihr habt euch dieses krasse thema prozent gewünscht und bekommt jetzt. Alle facts dazu wie weit ist die forschung
Zur chronik welche herausforderung gibt es und werden wir vielleicht bald ewig. Leben können jetzt den. Klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Vielen dank für diesen themenvorschlag und wie ihr mir auch bei whatsapp oder den anderen messenger
Themenvorschläge machen könnte das erfahrt. Ihr am ende des videos
einfrieren auftauen und einfach weiterleben statt
Zu sterben ging mal wieder nach science-fiction pur wird aber vielleicht bald realität oder nicht das thema ist hochaktuell
Dabei, hat sich der erste mensch schon vor gut 50. Jahren nach seinem tod
einfrieren lassen die leiche vom amerikaner james bedford liegt seit
Januar 1964 gut gekühlt bei minus 190 grad in einem mit teil tank
Er selbst aber auch seine anhänger gehen fest davon aus dass
Er eines tages wieder leben wird teams aus medizinerinnen. Und mediziner dagegen sehen das ganze
Etwas, kritischer viel erhalten ist für komplett unrealistisch
vor allem in dem fall bedford denn schließlich wurde, er von 50
jahren
Noch mit einer ganz anderen technik eingefroren als heute der fachbegriff für das ganze laut chronik und selbst
heute gibt es technisch gesehen noch viele
herausforderungen das größte problem sind wohl die kristalle die sich beim einfrieren im körper bilden in bedford fall wurde seinem blut deswegen auch durch
Frostschutzmittel ersetzen damit sein gewebe nicht zerplatzt wie eine flasche die, man
im tiefkühlschrank vergessen hat anhänger der kryonik berufen sich in ihrem glauben oft auf den fall der schwedin anna b 9
Sie stürzte bei einem unfall unter die eisdecke eines flusses und konnte erst eine stunde später gerettet werden durch eine luftblase
Konnte sie zwar atmen doch sie war klinisch tot es. Konnten. Keine, ihren. Aktivitäten gemessen werden sie atmete nicht
Und ihre körpertemperatur lag unter 14 grad celsius das ärzte-team
Reanimierte sie wärmte das blut auf und schlossen sie an einer herz. Kreislauf maschine an und tatsächlich
Anna wachte auf und es blieben. Keine bleibende schäden der grund. Dafür
Ihr gehirn wurde sehr schnell abgekühlt und wurde so in einem unbeschädigten zustand konserviert inzwischen setzen viele forschungsteams
Einen ähnliche technik, ein, um operationen am herzen durchzuführen doch zurück zum fall bedford
Er war gestorben an einem tumor. Und genau das ist das nächste problem denn selbst wenn
Forschungsteams ist in der zukunft schaffen. Könnten seinen, kompletten organismus wieder. Zu beleben würde der sterbevorgang
Absolut sofort wieder einsetzen. Um das zu vermeiden müssen, irgendwie alle zellen für jugend werden wie auch
Immer man das schaffen will ja und ein ähnliches szenario das hat sich auch
Ein 14 jähriges mädchen aus london entstanden bericht hat sie durchgesetzt dass sie nach ihrem tod, eingefroren wird wenn
Sie pocht auf ihr recht auf ein späteres leben wenn es forschungsteams irgendwann einmal gelungen sein sollte den krebs
Zu therapieren dazu die junge briten ich glaube die konservierung durch, ein frieden gibt mir die chance
Geheilt und wieder aufgeweckt zu werden und wenn es erst in hunderten von. Jahren ist konkret funktioniert die technik
So die menschlichen körper werden auf minus 196 grad heruntergekühlt
Und in behältern mit flüssigem stickstoff gelagert ähnlich wie auch in dem fall bedford vor 50
Jahren, wird das blut ersetzt durch eine spezielle kühlflüssigkeit. Um
Zu verhindern dass zellen beschädigt werden das gewebe wird schlagartig herunter gekühlt damit. Sich keine, eiskristalle bilden die zellen verletzen
Könnten das gewebe wird. So zu einer brüchigen
glasartige
Substanz die unternehmen in russland und den usa beispielsweise die diese technik derzeit anbieten
Konzentrieren konzentrieren sich meist auf die perfekte konservierung des gehirns als dem wichtigsten menschlichen organ alles andere wäre kaum zu stemmen
dann, müsste man nämlich in jedem zelltyp
Ein anderes spezielles frostschutzmittel einsetzen die anhänger der kryonik gehen
Davon, aus dass künstlich hergestelltes biologisches material in zukunft
Alle anderen körperstrukturen ersetzen kann die kosten eingefroren in tiefkühl behältern gelagert zu werden sind nicht
Ohne in russland kostet das bis
Zu 150000 euro, sparen kann man wenn, man
Nur einzelne organe oder im kopf einfriert rechtlich gesehen ist es in deutschland nicht möglich langfristig eingelagert
Zu werden denn das gilt als bestattung doch es geht schon tatsächlich
Und funktioniert auch nur nicht mit ausgewachsenen menschen sondern mitteilen im kleinen rahmen
Die chronik nämlich oder eine art chronik nämlich sogar in deutschland beispielsweise gibt es in leipzig. Ein
Unternehmen dass stammzellen von neugeborenen einfriert 3400 euro kosten das für 25. Jahre falls also bei den menschen später in seinem
leben mal
Ein knorpel abgenutzt sein sollte können aus den eingefrorenen
Stammzellen neuer knorpel gezüchtet werden das fazit. Zur chronik ist also durchwachsen die
Meisten seriösen wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler hals für quatsch dass menschen eingefroren. Und aufgetaut werden
Um, dann, einfach weiterzuleben selbst in der zukunft sei das technisch kaum zu realisieren
Selbst die vielen anhänger der chronik selbst halten eine erfolgreiche reanimation in der zukunft für eher
Unwahrscheinlich sie schätzen die wahrscheinlichkeit bei dem aktuellen technischen know how bei etwa fünf prozent naja aber ist ja schon
Mal was mal sehen ob die chancen in zukunft steigen wenn. Ihr zu den ersten gehören
Wollte die neueste zu erfahren dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp wenn. Ihr wollt könnt
Ihr euch auch mit mir über telegrammen instagram oder den facebook messenger verknüpfen dann erfahrt
ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video tag nicht garantiert
Ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von kling zum mitmachen. Und zum beispiel themen vorschlagen einfach hier draufklicken
Und zur begrüßung habe ich ein kleines goodie für euch im begrüßungstext versteckt natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau, mit dem blogger vergessen hier geht es weiter. Dafür auch draufklicken ist der tod tödlich oder leben wir weiter
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran